wir sind zwei es ist 12 am 13 dezember
2018 bund heute muss ich schon wieder
durch hier gar nicht groß rum la wir
werden in zwei stunden und 19 minuten
drei weisheitszähne gezogen
ich werde dabei verrecken bevor ich dazu
kommen was heute und in diesem video
passieren wird einen blick zurück im
november 2017 habe ich auf einmal eine
richtig heftigen schnupfen bekommen ich
hatte hier da und da hin wenn immer für
1000 euro lymphknoten eine richtig
krasse schwellung der lymphknoten war
gefühlt auf basketball der will der
grund dafür war eine kleine liebenswerte
hier unten links in meinem tiefer
nämlich ein weisheitszahn der sich
entzündet hatte das musste raus also bin
ich zum zahnarzt gegangen und habe mir
meinen ersten weisheitszahn unten links
ziehen lassen
die ganze sache machen nicht sogar in
unter einer weise entzündet war es war
schon unangenehm auf jeden fall ich
konnte obwohl doch es war auch nicht
gestellt essen und mainz heute ja also
die müssen alle raus kleine rote und
deswegen sind sich heute hier leute hat
ein bisschen schiss aber ich weiß dass
es extrem viele menschen aus so geht das
ihre weiße zähne gezogen werden deswegen
mache ich dieses video um zu
dokumentieren wie unnormal geiles ist
wenn man drei städte löcher in seinem
mund raum hat die ganze sache wird wenn
wir so ablaufen dass ich in einen
tiefschlaf sollte direkt das genannt
versetzt werde meine beiden weiter nach
oben sind schon ganz raus aus dem
zahnfleisch den ein wenig nach unten
rechts habe der ist nur halbe raus heißt
das schauen sie die oberen ränge aus dem
zahnfleisch raus und da wird mein
chirurg ein bisschen ich habe auf jeden
fall bisschen schiss davor leute aber
jetzt genug arbeit wir springen jetzt im
kieferchirurg
[Musik]
stocker für perovic aber ich habe ja das
ist immer mein traum ist wirklichkeit
aber soweit kommt hält nicht sagen die
leute nicht gemerkt habe christoph
wissen wir das ist einfach später meinen
mund ist nicht mehr so traut die rechte
seite was ein bisschen aber ich kann
schon wieder halbwegs reden
ich habe hier mit der geige konstruktion
der bergzone halstuch einfach so links
um sexuelle akt reingesteckt basiert
aber anfang nach der op sooo 0 rolle in
der runde drin und so drauf gebissen hat
habe ich noch eine stunde wieder
rausgenommen weil das wir ab so gesagt
hat durchgehend wann immer ich das
schmerzmittel um zu verhindern dass es
große schmerzen bekommen ich hab ich ja
keine schmerzen gehabt eigentlich
wahrscheinlich heute nacht aber dass das
so weiter traditionen deutet so weit
habe ich noch keine stellung
hoffentlich läuft auf sein meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren bis der
hamster nodes aktiviert worden
möglicherweise über jegliche menschliche
vorstellungskraft hinaus angeschwollen
hab ich horche unverstellt jahre nicht
wirklich als erster den schuldigen es
gibt aber fertig aus ganz normal glaube
ich immer halten sich drei zähne ziehen
lassen hat aber ihr seht hier
wenn ich von vorn drauf schaut hier habe
ich so eine schwellung weil hier wurde
unten eine wirkliche ausgegraben der
wahl noch tiefenthal verstritten oben
rechts einer gezogen da draußen war oben
links einrichtungen raus macht an der
stelle wo die zähne schon draußen waren
beste leben gar kein problem rechts
weiter positiv ist ein gespann schmerzen
habe ich keiner und ich sage es mal so
es wird natürlich der neiße food
konsumiert eine super form einer mutter
die sie eventuell mysteriös aus aber
dies sogar wurzelgemüse mit frischen
meyer von hier mal treuer begleiter die
schmerztablette ich nehme sie jetzt an
ihrem zweiten tag gar nicht regelmäßig
mehr ein
zwischendrin mal eine wenn ich mir denke
ich könnte mal wieder für alle sechs
sieben stunden oder so aber sonst geht
es mir nicht gut
heute ist es so langweilig ich habe
nichts zu tun immerhin ist jetzt mag es
zwischenzeitig mal gekommen war unser
schönster morgen geburtstag art kommt
sie keinen rappen kellergang wurzeln
[Musik]
da geht es ja auf jeden fall leute jetzt
nochmal backen
ich sehe immer noch ein bisschen
verwahrlost aus haag 2 der abend und die
sperrung ist die schweren dinge auf
einer seite habe ich schon geschafft
wie sich das wasser sammelt in einer
nach der eröffnung gibt's eröffnen tag 3
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ganz kurz der formcheck wie sieht die
backe aus bitter aber die kamera nach
oben wo weißt du wie du aussiehst nun
hin geschichten gibt es keinen direkten
vergleich sollte ich hab's gefühl dass
es jetzt ein bisschen besser als gestern
was mache ich zu den ganzen tag über ich
habe heute noch zwei ibuprofen 600
genommen glaube ich war so ganz ohne
schmerzmittel ist immer noch unangenehm
ich kühler mit tiefgefrorenen erbsen
glaub mir das ist der tipp meine große
hoffnung ist jetzt dass es jetzt tag 3
also hoffentlich diese einseitige
hamster bucky morgen will ich bin auf
dem weg von das nach oben geht war ich
damit nur einen geben die leute gute
besseren gewandelt
und jetzt sollte der finalshow und tag 5
ist erreicht
wie sieht's aus mit blick auf jeden fall
ohne scheiße das ist so ein film also
erst mal ich hab mir die backen hat so
die chance wirklich schon zurückgegangen
das jetzt fünf heute ist der siebzehnte
aber die mich mal die banken sind gar
nicht mehr so sehr geschwollen
ach so heute passiert ist es das hier
aber so einen gelben fleck am kiewer
bekommen wir maximal das sei normal es
ist bei mir eigentlich recht normale
sachen aufpassen kann den mund nicht
ganz aufmachen und nicht fest zubeißen
sonst kann ja nicht alles essen
ich kann nicht wirklich lachen also wenn
diese sache merke ich hier reden wie die
fehlen so ziehen die wir drei tagen
gezogen gedanken oder und ich hoffe ich
kann im urlaub wieder skifahren saufen
und ich hoffe es kommt ein paar von euch
die angst nehmen oder euch zeigen sich
eigentlich auch so verlaufen kann ich
doch ich habe relativ guten verlauf
hierfür natürlich persönlich
vorgeschlagen des biotech es gerne ab
schaut weiter und bis zum nächsten mal
wenn wir jetzt hier gezogen werden es
sei dadurch nicht